pour françois hollande
cette journée avait le goût de la
victoire
après avoir répondu favorablement à
l'appel au secours du président malien
traoré
les troupes françaises et est accueilli
en triomphe à tombouctou
mais neuf ans plus tard la france n'est
plus elle a fait tout ça elle
5100 soldats doivent surveiller un
espace de plusieurs millions de
kilomètres carrés et si longtemps
empêché la chute des grandes villes
maliennes ils n'ont pas réussi à venir à
bout des djihadistes qui ont étendu
leurs actions aux pays voisins
les jihadistes ont réussi à s'infiltrer
dans toutes les régions alentours
notamment dans la zone des trois
frontières entre le mali le burkina faso
et le niger est aussi celle là je pense
leur principale victoire stratégique ils
ont réussi à s'infiltrer dans le centre
du mali dans la région de mopti en
s'appuyant sur les conflits
intercommunautaires
l'objectif de barkan était d'aider les
armées locales à se structurer pour
assurer elles mêmes la sécurité de la
région
mais le g5 celle composée de troupes
mauritaniennes malienne pour keane ab
nigérienne et tchadienne reste fragile
au printemps dernier le tchad a réduit
de moitié sa contribution après la mort
du président déby et au bali les deux
coups d'état successifs ont aussi changé
la donne politique
quant à la force takouba qui réunit la
france et ses partenaires européens elle
pourrait elle aussi se retirer du mali
nous ne pouvons pas sécuriser des zones
qui retombe dans l'anomie parce que des
états décident de ne pas prendre leurs
responsabilités
les relations entre bamako et paris sont
plus tendue que jamais
l'ambassadeur français a été expulsé et
la population malienne exprime sa colère
devant des troupes étrangères engagées
dans le nord du pays depuis plus de neuf
ans
pourtant un retrait total de la force
barkan est peu probable
si la france à cause de cette crispation
bamako paris quitte tout le sel est tous
là toute l'afrique de l'ouest ce serait
évidemment une perte d'influencé
considérable pour la france et du coup
une perte de prestige international pour
la france paris pourrait re déployé ses
forces dans les pays voisins également
menacé par les djihadistes
53 soldats français sont morts au sahel
depuis le début de cette opération
extérieure la plus longue depuis la
guerre d'algérie